สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนโอเคกลับมาเจอกับเราสอง
คนนะครับในช่อง complate
นะครับวันนี้มาเจอกันวันเจอแล้วฟังแล้วก็
กดไลค์กดแชร์กด Subscribe นะคะ
ขายของตั้งแต่เริ่มต้นนะคะจะได้มีคนมาดู
เยอะๆไงจะได้มีคนมาเรียนภาษาไทยเยอะๆมีคน
มาเที่ยวประเทศไทยเยอะๆ
เป็นยังไงคะ
สบายดีครับสบายดีอ่าวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวัน
หยุด
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันพฤหัสบดีที่ 4 เดือนพฤษภาคม
เดือนที่ 5 นะคะ
วันนี้
วันที่
วันที่ใน
วันฉัตรมงคล
คือจริงๆวันนี้เราจะไม่ได้คุยเรื่องวัน
ฉัตรมงคลนะคะ
เอาเป็นว่าวันนี้ชื่อวันหยุด
นะคะ
ไม่ต้องไปทำงานไม่ได้ไปทำงานก็เลยมีเวลา
มาอัด
วิดีโอภาษาไทยให้นักเรียนจริงๆนิดนึงนะ
เดือนที่ 5 เป็นเดือนที่มีวันหยุดเยอะใช่
ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
หยุดเฉพาะเฉพาะบางคน
ใช่ครับ
วันนี้วันนี้อากาศประมาณเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋เช็ค
ก่อนน่าจะ 34 นะคะมีเพื่อนบ่นร้อนมากๆ
กรมอุตุบอกว่าวันนี้จะเป็นวันที่ร้อนที่
สุด
ใช่
ร้อนที่สุดก็
[เพลง]
แถวนี้ก็อยู่ที่
36 ว้าว
อุณหภูมินะคะนักเรียน 36 องศาเซลเซียส
อุณหภูมิ 36 องศาเซลเซียส
พี่ก็ 25 เหมือน
มีรีโมทแล้วเราก็เปิดแอร์
นะครับ
ครูเอ๋ก็ไม่ค่อยออกจากบ้านก็อยู่เฉพาะใน
บ้านเวลาได้ยินคุณบอกร้อนๆอะไรร้อนเปิด
ประตูออกไปข้างนอก
จริงๆด้วยร้อนมากนะคะ
โอเคเมื่อกี้เมื่อกี้นี้ที่คุยถามครู
อาร์ตี้เนาะสบายดีไหม
เราเจอกันกี่โมงเนี่ย 3 โมง
นะวันนี้ที่เราเจอกันบ่าย 3 โมง 20 นะคะ
วันนี้มีเรื่องจะปรึกษา
มีเรื่องอะไรครับจะปรึกษา
คุยกันดีกว่า
อ๋อมีสิ่งที่อยากรู้อยากจะถามใช่ไหมโอเค
เรื่องอะไรเรื่องอะไร
หรอ
2 คนจะออกกำลังกาย
ออกกำลังกายแล้วตอนนี้กำลังแพร่เชื้อออก
กำลังกาย
ก็แปลว่าให้ทุกคนสุขภาพดีไงปกติก็อยากให้
ทุกคนสุขภาพดี
ก็ออกกำลังกายเนี่ยก็ไปที่ครูเรียมครู
เรียมก็กำลังออกกำลังกายใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ก็
เริ่มค่ะเริ่มหลังจากที่ไม่ได้ทำไม่ได้
ออกกำลังกายประมาณ 2 ปีโอ้ 2 ปีเลย
ยังไม่เต็ม 2 ปี
ถึงอย่างนี้คือต้องบอกว่า
ปกติเนี่ย
เอ้ยไม่ใช่ปกติไหมคือเมื่อก่อนทำงานก็
ต้องออกจากบ้านไปที่ทำงานก็จะได้เดินได้
วิ่งคือวิ่งไปขึ้นรถนะคะ
แต่ตอนนี้พอทำงานที่บ้านน่ะก็
นั่ง
อ๋อนั่งเยอะไม่ต้องเดินไปขึ้นรถไม่ต้อง
วิ่งไปขึ้นรถเมล์แล้วใช่ไหมก็เดินนิด
หน่อยนะคะแล้วก็นั่งแล้วก็พูดบางวันก็อาจ
จะยืน
ใช่ไหม
คะพูดมากๆก็เหนื่อยก็ง่วงนอนก็หันหลังนอน
เลย
อยู่ไม่ไกลใช่ไหมอยู่ไม่ไกลอยู่ในบ้าน
ก็เลยรู้สึกว่า
ร่างกายน่ะมันไม่มีแรง
เหนื่อยง่าย
หายใจ
ไม่ค่อยดี
ก็เลยไป
เมื่อวัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์ก็จะหาเรื่องออกไปข้างนอก
แล้วก็เดิน
นะคะเดินแต่ว่าก็กลัวโควิดนิดๆนะก็จะไม่
ไปที่คนเยอะๆ
เมื่อวันอาทิตย์ที่ผ่านมาก็ไปเดิน
เดินในในสวนน่ะมีต้นไม้แล้วก็รู้สึกดีรู้
สึกดีขึ้นวันจันทร์ก็เลยออกกำลังกายออก
กำลังกายแต่ออกเยอะไปคือออกกำลังกายของ
ครูเอ๋ก็คือถูบ้าน
ทำงานบ้านแล้วก็เสร็จแล้วไม่พอก็อะไรนะ
แต่ว่าครูเอ๋ไม่ได้โยคะมา 2 ปี
คือนักเรียนรู้จักเส้นไหมคะว่าติ้วจาก
เส้นไหม
ตามก็คือเส้นที่อยู่ข้างในในแขนเราเนี่ย
ทำยังไงให้เส้นขึ้นมา
เส้นมันทำให้เราขยับมือได้
[เพลง]
อย่างนี้ก็เป็นเส้น
เส้นเป็นเส้น
เส้นนะคะไม่ใช่กระดูกเนาะเห็นชัดเลยนะคะ
ทีนี้เนี่ย
คือเวลาที่เราโยคะคือการยืด
อยู่ไหนอุปกรณ์ที่คุณเอ็ดเตรียมไว้ไม่
เป็นไรเอาที่ผมเนี่ย
อันนี้ตัวนี้เป็นเป็นอะไรนะยางรัดผมใช่
ไหมคะอย่างนั้นผมเนี่ย
มันยืดได้ยืด
แล้วก็ปล่อย
ทิ้งถ้าเรายืดจนสุดเนี่ยมันจะตึง
เออใช่
แบบนี้
เป็นในตัวเหมือนกันนักเรียนซึ่งในตัวเรา
เนี่ยเรายื่นได้ใช่ไหม
ยืดเส้น
ครูเอกก็เลยยืดเส้นเยอะไปหน่อยแล้วก็
ทำนู่นทำนี่เยอะประมาณ 5 ชั่วโมงว้าว 5
ชั่วโมงนานมากนะครับถ้าออกกำลังกาย 5
ชั่วโมงยืดเส้น 5 ชั่วโมงเย็นไปถึง 2
ทุ่ม
สนุกกับตัวเองมาก
แล้วครูอาร์ตี้ลองคิดวันต่อไปจะเกิดอะไร
ขึ้น
วันต่อไปก็สบายเลยครับแข็งแรงเลยวันนี้
ออกกำลังกายเยอะใช่ไหมใช่ไหม
วันต่อไปเป็นอะไร
ระบมค่ะ
ไม่ได้ออกกำลังกาย
เพราะว่าเมื่อวานออกกำลังกายมากมากเกินไป
ใช่ไหมใช่
ก็คือว่า
ครูเอ๋ก็ลืมไม่ได้ออกกำลังกายนานๆควรจะ
เริ่มทีละนิดทีละนิดใช่
เยอะเลยนะคะทำทั้งหมดต่อเนื่อง
มากเกินไปตอนนี้นะคะ
จับตรงนี้ก็โอ้ยจับเอว
โอยดับขาก็โอ้ยมัน
ปวดอ่ะค่ะมันจะ
คือมีอาการเหมือนโดนทุบนักเรียนเหมือนโดน
ทุบ
อีกวันนึงเจ็บอ่ะ
คือจะปรึกษาครูอาร์ตี้ว่า
ระบมเนี่ย
ควรจะ
ทำต่อหรือว่าหยุดครูเอกก็คิด
ต่อไม่
หยุด
บางคนก็บอกว่า
เจ็บแล้วระบมแล้วต้องทำต่อห้ามหยุดเพราะ
ว่าถ้าหยุดแล้วมาทำใหม่ก็ระบมใหม่ทำไป
เรื่อยๆจนร่างกายหยุดระบบ
ต้องอดทนเยอะๆใช่ไหมครับ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
หยุดก่อนดีคะน้ำหนักคนที่วิ่งบ่อยๆ
ตอนที่เวลาที่หยุดไปนานๆแล้วไม่ได้ออก
กำลังกายแล้วกลับมาออกกำลังกายเนี่ยเราจะ
ต้องค่อยๆเพิ่มออกทีละนิดทีละนิดค่อยๆ
เพิ่มไปเหมือนที่ครูเอ๋บอกนั่นแหละเออ
สมมุติว่าเราไม่เคยไม่เคยวิ่งเลยแล้วเรา
อยากที่จะวิ่งวันแรกวันแรกที่เราออกไป
เนี่ยก็อย่าเพิ่งวิ่งให้เราเดินเร็วๆก่อน
เดินเร็วๆก่อนอ่าแล้ววันต่อไปวันต่อไป
สำหรับโคโยตี้เนี่ยมันมีมันมีคนที่คิดว่า
มันจะมีวิธีการฟื้นฟูของร่างกายเนี่ย
ร่างกายเนี่ยจะฟื้นฟูตัวเองเนี่ยใช้เวลา
48 ชั่วโมง 48 ชั่วโมง
ใช่ก็คือ 2 วัน
อ๋อฉะนั้นแปลว่าถ้าเจ็บแล้วก็ต้องหยุดสัก
2 วันก็หยุดประมาณ 1 วันแล้วก็เว้น 1
วันออกกำลังกาย 1 วันเว้น 1 วันพอดีอ๋อ
ใช่ครับ
หยุดมา 3 วันแล้ว
[เพลง]
ปกติเซลล์ของเราเนี่ยเซลล์ของเราเนี่ยทุก
ๆวันเซลล์จะตายลงทุกวัน
แล้วทุกๆวันเซลล์จะสร้างใหม่
ทุกวันที่เซลล์ที่สร้างใหม่เนี่ยเซลล์จะ
ไป Copy  sale ที่ไปเมื่อวาน
ใช่ครับถ้าเมื่อวานเซลล์ออกกำลังกายมาก
แข็งแรงมากสมองจะรู้และว่าเซลล์ต่อไปที่
จะสร้างใหม่เนี่ยจะต้องสร้างเซลล์ให้แข็ง
แรงกว่าเดิม
ใช่เป็นธรรมชาติของคนของเซลล์เพราะฉะนั้น
เพราะฉะนั้นเวลาออกกำลังกายวันนี้วันนี้
เราออกกำลังกายไปแล้วพรุ่งนี้หยุด
วันต่อไปเราไปออกกำลังกายซ้ำได้แล้วเซลล์
ที่เซลล์ใหม่ทุกวันจะแข็งแรงขึ้นทุกๆวัน
ทุกๆวันทุกๆวันแล้วจริงๆควรออกเยอะประมาณ
ประมาณเท่าไหร่ก็ออกค่อยๆเพิ่มไปครับ
อย่างเช่นอย่างเช่น
ครัวตี้เนี่ยครั้งแรกที่โคโยตี้หยุดไม่
ได้วิ่งนานๆนะครับอ่าประมาณที่โคโยตี้
เริ่มกลับมาวิ่งเนี่ยประมาณ 2-3 ปีหยุด
วิ่งเนี่ยวันแรกที่โคโยตี้ไปวิ่งก็จะวิ่ง
แค่ประมาณ 200 เมตร
ไม่ได้จับเวลาใช่ไหมคะไม่ได้จับเวลา 5
วินาทีใช่ๆแล้วก็หยุดแล้ววันต่อไปก็เพิ่ม
ขึ้นเพิ่มเป็น 500 เมตร
ใช่แล้วค่อยๆเพิ่มไป
วิ่งแล้วก็หยุดวิ่ง 1 วันหยุด 1 วันวิ่ง 1
วันหยุด 1 วันแล้วก็เพิ่ม
500 เมตรเป็น 1 กิโลเมตรเป็น 3 กิโลเมตร
ค่อยๆเพิ่มไป
แล้วเราจะไม่เจ็บ
เนี่ยประมาณกี่กิโลเมตร
ที่วิ่งมากที่สุดก็คือพี่ไปวิ่งในงานของ
มาราธอนนั่นแหละครับประมาณ 56 กิโล
เป็นยังไงอ่ะ
ต้องซ้อมมาเยอะๆนะครับสิ่งที่ไม่ใช่ซ้อม
นานเท่าไหร่คะ
หรือว่า 7 วันอาทิตย์
ก็คือเฉลี่ย 1 วันหยุด 1 วันวิ่ง 1 วัน
อ๋อไม่จำเป็นต้องวิ่งทุกวันใช่ไหมเพราะ
ว่าเพราะว่าจริงๆอ่ะครูเอกเคยได้ยินคนนึง
นะคะคนที่ครูเอ๋รู้จักพยายามบอกไปวิ่ง
วิ่งทุกวันไปเดินเดินทุกวันแล้วมันเจ็บไง
พอมันเจ็บแล้วเราก็รู้สึกไม่ไหวเขาบอก
เยอะๆเยอะๆแต่เราก็เอ๊ะทำไมต้องทำเยอะๆ
คือก็รู้สึกนะว่าเยอะๆแล้วมันเจ็บไงเออก็
เลยต้องปรึกษาครูอาร์ตี้วันนี้แหละก็
สำหรับโคโยตี้คิดว่าเอ่อโคโยตี้ออกกำลัง
กายเพื่อเพื่อให้ร่างกายแข็งแรงเราต้อง
สนุกด้วยมีความสุขด้วยถ้าเราเจ็บแล้วเรา
ก็ไม่วิ่งแบบเนี้ยก็ไม่สนุกใช่มั้ยครับ
ใช่ก็เลยไม่อยากวิ่ง
แต่ก็เลยใช้โยคะใช้อะไรนะแอโรบิคใช้ฟัง
เพลงแล้วก็เต้นอะไรก็ไม่รู้เออได้เหมือน
กันเราสามารถออกกำลังกายได้หลายๆแบบนะ
ครับไม่จำเป็นต้องวิ่งใครชอบโยคะก็ไปยกซะ
ใครชอบเต้นก็ไปเต้นใครชอบเดินไปเดินได้
แต่ว่าบังเอิญบังเอิญหยุดนานแล้วก็เยอะ
เกินไป
เคยแบบเหมือนกับว่าเคยๆพลาดด้วยการแบบทำ
เยอะเกินไปเกินที่ร่างกายจะรับได้เคยไหม
คะอ๋อควรที่จะสังเกตตัวเองจะสังเกตตัวเอง
ถ้ารู้สึกว่ามันเยอะเกินไปหรือจะเวลาเวลา
ที่ออกกำลังกายมากเกินไปกว่าที่ก็จะพออาจ
จะรู้ได้ยังไงคะว่าตอนนี้มากเกินไปละคือ
ดูที่เวลาดูที่ระยะทางหรือดูที่ร่างกาย
เหนื่อย
สำหรับโคโยตี้โคโยตี้วิ่งใช่ไหมพอโคโยตี้
วิ่งในโคโยตี้ก็จะจับเวลาได้จะรู้ระยะทาง
รู้ระยะเวลาแล้วก็จะรู้ตัวเองว่าเรา
เหนื่อยมากมากหรือยัง
จ่ายก็สังเกตตัวเองสังเกตเอ่อการหายใจของ
ตัวเองสังเกตเอ่อการเต้นของหัวใจหากว่า
เราเหนื่อยหรือยังนะครับ
[เพลง]
ก็ไม่ได้รู้สึกไม่ได้รู้สึกว่าเหนื่อย
อะไรมากนะคะก็ก็เรื่อยๆคือไม่ได้ทำเร็วๆ
แต่ว่าทำไปเรื่อยๆแต่ก็เริ่มรู้สึก
สนุกแล้วอยู่ในบ้านมันก็ไม่มีเงินไง
ไม่มีเหงื่อไม่ร้อนแต่พอรู้สึกแปลกๆก็เลย
หยุดพอหลังจากหยุดเนี่ยโอ้โหร้อนเหงื่อ
ออก
เหงื่อออกก็เลยรู้ว่าอ๋ออันนี้เยอะแล้ว
แล้วหลังจากนั้นก็คือระบบ
ก็เลยระบมนะคะก็คืออันนี้ก็
ควบคุมได้ไม่เคยมากเกินไป
แต่แรกๆอ่ะคือหยุดไป 10 ปีแล้วมาเริ่ม
เริ่มวันแรก
6 เดือนก่อนวิ่งมาราธอน
เป็นยังไงคะระบมไหมก็มีบ้างครับมีบ้างที่
ระบบเพราะว่าเพราะว่าโคโยตี้ต้องการเพิ่ม
ระยะสมมุติโคโยตี้วิ่ง 3 กมแล้ววันนี้
ต้องการที่จะเพิ่มเป็น 5 กิโลเป็นการ
เพิ่มระยะจาก 3 เป็น 5 กิโลใช่ไหมครับอัน
นี้มันก็ต้องมีมีช่วงที่ต้องต้องใช้ร่าง
กายให้มากกว่า 3 กิโลที่เคยทำได้ใช่เป็น 5
กิโลอันนี้ก็จะต้องมีความ
กล้ามเนื้อก็จะต้องเจ็บปวดบ้างนะครับนิด
หน่อยนิดหน่อยแต่เราก็พักนะครับโคโยตี้ก็
จะพักสัก 1 วันนะครับแล้วก็หยุดแล้วก็
วิ่งอีก 1 วันใช่คือต้องบอกว่าครูอาร์ตี้
เขาออกกำลังกายประจำมาก่อนเขาจะรู้ว่าอ๋อ
อันนี้อันนี้เจ็บแบบนี้ดี
ไม่ใช่เจ็บแบบแย่ไม่ใช่แบบเจ็บปวดนะครับ
เป็นการเจ็บแบบเอ่อกล้ามเนื้อพัฒนาขึ้น
เพื่อให้แข็งแรงขึ้น
ค่ะแล้วก็เจ็บมา 3 วันนะคะ
ยังไม่หยุดเจ็บนะคะ
ดังนั้นเนี่ย
ครูเอกสามารถ
อะไรคะครูเอกก็สามารถออกกำลังกลับไปออก
กำลังกายใหม่เบาๆได้ไม่ต้องมากเท่าเท่า
วันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์นะเดินเดินเฉยๆไม่เรื่อยๆไม่มี
อะไรมากเดินหยุดเดินหยุดแต่วันจันทร์วัน
จันทร์บ้า
วันจันทร์ว่าไงนักเรียนเป็นบ้าแต่ว่า
เนื่องจากเอ๋รู้สึกว่าหัวใจมันเต้นช้า
แล้วมันเหนื่อยก็เลยออกมาทำอะไรเพราะว่า
ถ้าเราไม่ออกกำลังกายไม่ใช้แรงเลยอ่ะร่าง
กายก็จะคิดว่าไม่ต้องใช้เมื่อร่างกายคิด
ว่าไม่ต้องใช้เราก็จะเดินช้าลงหัวใจก็จะ
เต้นช้าลงหายใจเข้าหายใจออกก็จะเหนื่อย
แล้วก็ช้าลงดังนั้นเนี่ยคุณหมอก็บอกเอง
ว่าเอ๋ต้องออกกำลังกาย
นะคะหมอก็บอกว่าเอฟรู้สึกเหมือนคนเหนื่อย
อ่ะหายใจเหนื่อย
ง่ายหรอใช่แล้วพอเริ่มออกกำลังกายมันรู้
สึกเฮ้ยมันไม่เหนื่อยแต่หลังจากนั้นนะคะ
มากไปนะคะว่าต้องค่อยๆทำนะครับอย่างที่
โคโยตี้บอกนะครับว่า
ร่างกายของเราเซลล์ของเราร่างกายพยายามจะ
สร้างเซลล์ที่แข็งแรงขึ้นทุกๆวันถ้าเรา
ไม่ได้ใช้ร่างกายให้ให้เต็มศักยภาพที่ที่
เราจะทำงานได้สมองก็จะรู้ว่าอ๋อไม่ต้อง
สร้างเซลล์ที่แข็งแรงมากก็ได้สร้างเซลล์
ที่ทำงานแบบปกติก็ได้
แล้วเราก็จะก็จะไม่ไม่แข็งแรงถ้าเป็นภาษา
ไทยเรียกว่าไม่ฟิตภาษาอังกฤษก็ฟิตเหมือน
กันนะดูไม่ฟิตไม่กระชับกระเฉงไม่ติด
แต่ถ้าเราออกกำลังกายเนี่ย
มันจะเป็นเซลล์ที่แข็งแรง
แรงขึ้นแข็งแรงขึ้นเราก็จะรู้สึกกระฉับ
กระเฉด
สำหรับคนออกกำลังกายค่ะเมื่อกี้ที่ครู
แอนตี้บอกว่าสมองก็จะสั่งใช่ไหมตรงนี้มี
นักเรียนคนนึงบอกเองว่าครูเอ๋คุณรู้ไหม
สมองอ่ะเขาจะจำถ้าคุณไม่ออกกำลังกายสมอง
ก็จะทำให้คุณน่ะ
ตัวนี้ไม่ต้องใช้ไม่เป็นไรไอ้ตัวนี้ไม่
ต้องใช้ไม่ต้องมีไม่ต้องมีไม่ต้องมีเรา
กล้ามเนื้อคุณจะน้อยลงแต่เวลาคุณจะออก
กำลังกายคุณก็ต้องทีละนิดสมองจะได้จำแล้ว
ก็ค่อยๆรู้ใช่แล้วก็จะดีขึ้นดีขึ้นแต่ถ้า
คุณทำทีเดียวสมองก็จะช็อค
ไม่ทันร่างกายก็ปรับตัวไม่ทันครับเซลล์ก็
สร้างเซลล์ที่แข็งแรงแข็งแรงยังไม่มาเลย
เดี๋ยวเราไปออกกำลังกายเยอะๆเราก็จะมี
อาการ
ปวดได้นะครับ
หรือสร้างกล้ามเนื้อ
คือกล้ามเนื้อกล้ามเนื้อยังไม่มีมีแต่
อะไรไม่มี
อะไรมีแต่ไขมันหรอ
ว่าเป็นผู้หญิงไม่อายนะคะนักเรียนเพราะ
ว่าต้องต้องสอนนักเรียนนะคะนี่กล้ามเนื้อ
หายไปหมดแล้วค่ะมีแต่อะไรไม่ทราบ
ไขมันนั่นแหละค่ะใครพลังงานสะสมครับ
ที่พร้อมใช้
เราต้องเอามาใช้ยังไงดีเราต้องค่อยๆออก
กำลังกายให้ร่างกายเริ่มรู้ว่าเราจำเป็น
จะต้องเอาพลังนั้นออกมาใช้แล้วร่างกายก็
จะค่อยๆเปลี่ยนเพิ่มกล้ามเนื้อเพิ่มความ
แข็งแรง
แต่ตรงนี้นะคะที่จะต้องทำเนี่ยครูเอกก็
ยอมรับนะคะครูอาร์ตี้ว่าครูเอ๋เนี่ยถ้า
ไม่ไม่บวกเลยก็ลบเลย
คือน้อยไปยังไง
ตัวเองไม่มีตรงกลาง
ตรงกลาง
มีเวลาทำอะไรก็แล้วแต่นะคะนักเรียนต้องมี
ตรงกลางตรงกลางเรียกว่าพอดีพอดีอ่ะเขา
เรียกว่าสายกลางสายกลางก็คือให้มันพอดี
ไม่ไม่ไปทางนี้มากไม่ไปขวามากไปหรือไม่ไป
ซ้ายมากไป
หยุดก็หยุดเลย
ทำก็ทำเยอะเลยแล้วก็เจ็บเลยอันนี้ไม่ตรง
กลางนะคะไม่สายกลาง
พูดถึงสายพานครับอะไรนะครับสายกลางยังไง
ครับคือจะบอกว่าพูดถึงสายกลางเนี่ยคือการ
ออกกำลังกายที่ที่เป็นสายกลางก็คือค่อยๆ
เพิ่มทีละนิดต้องรู้ร่างกายว่า
รับได้เท่าไหร่แต่ละคนที่เหมือนกันนะ
อย่างครูอาร์ตี้วิ่งได้
10 กิโลเมตร
ถ้าครูเอกไปวิ่งก็อาจจะได้สัก 10 เมตร
10 เมตรนะคะ
ก็จะไม่เหนื่อยมาก
สำคัญคือไม่บาดเจ็บก็คือไม่เจ็บ
นะคะทีนี้พอพอเรื่องนี้เอ๋ก็เลยคิดขึ้นมา
ได้ว่า
ถ้าเป็นตัวอย่างให้ตัวเองเลยนะคะว่าทำ
อะไร
หลายครั้งน่ะที่เอ๋ทำอะไรแล้วไม่อยู่สาย
กลาง
คำว่าสายกลางคือไม่พอดีอ่ะนะคะไม่อยู่ตรง
กลางไม่มากไปก็น้อยไปครูเอกจะเป็นแบบนี้
หลายอย่างนะคะที่ไม่พอดีดังนั้นเนี่ยอะไร
ที่มันไม่พอดีอ่ะมันก็จะไม่ค่อยดีกับเรา
ไม่ดีกับเรา
ยกตัวอย่างนะเหมือนกับการกินอาหาร
[เพลง]
การกินอาหารนะคะเวลาที่เราเจออาหารที่
อร่อย
อร่อยคือเราชอบ
เราจะกินเท่าไหร่
บางทีเราไปสั่งอาหารหน่อย
หรือว่าบางทีนานๆออกจากบ้านทุกวันกิน
อาหารที่ตัวเองทำเพราะไปไปเที่ยวโอ้ยอัน
นี้ก็อร่อยอันนี้ก็อร่อยอันนี้ก็อร่อยกิน
ทุกร้าน
ก็เลยกินเยอะเลยเพราะอร่อยแบบนี้ก็มากไป
ใช่ไหมคะคือถ้าอร่อยแล้วเรากินมากเกินไป
เราก็จะอ้อปวดท้อง
ปวดท้องหรือไม่สบาย
แต่บางคนน่ะก็กลัวว่าไม่เอาฉันกลัวอ้วน
ชอบผอมเคยเห็นไหมคะ
คนที่ชอบผอมจนไม่กินน่ะ
เคยเห็นไหม
เคยเห็นส่วนใหญ่จะเป็นผู้หญิงเพื่อน
โคโยตี้ก็มีเป็นเพื่อนผู้หญิงนะครับก็ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่ก็ไม่อยากไม่อยากกิน
เยอะไม่อยากอ้วนไงนะ
พอดีพอดีพอดี
แต่เขามีคือที่เอ๋บอกว่าผอมมากคือเอ๋เคย
เจอที่ที่แบบเห็นเห็นเป็นกระดูกเลยอ่ะค่ะ
กระดูกก็น่ารัก
แล้วจะเห็นแต่กระดูก
คือเรายังมีเนื้อไงเรายังมีเนื้อเอาบีบ
ยังไงก็มีเนื้อขลุ่ยเยอะแล้วหน้าเนี่ย
หน้าตอบ
ครูอาจจะต้องทำหน้าตอบเลยนะ
พระเอก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
มากๆเลยอ่ะค่ะ
อันนี้ไม่ได้เนาะ 2 คนก็ทำไม่ได้นะคะคือ
บางคนก็จะชอบนะคะชอบผอมมากหอมแบบไม่มี
เนื้อเลยนะคะคือคือเหมือนกับมีมีหนังมี
หนังแล้วก็มีกระดูกนะคะกระดูกก็ดูก่อน
ก็จะมีแบบนั้นอันนั้นก็น้อยเกินไปอย่าง
น้อยเกินไป
แล้ววันนึงจะอาจจะไม่สบายได้เพราะว่าสาร
อาหารไม่ครบหรือไวตามินหรือว่าโปรตีน
คาร์โบไฮเดรต
ก็ไม่ครบใช่ไหมคะ
อย่างเรื่องอาหารถ้ามากเกินไปก็ไม่ดีน้อย
เกินไปก็ไม่ดีเออาจจะมากไปครูอาร์ตี้จะพอ
ดีนะอาจจะน้อยไป
น่าจะพอดีเพราะว่า
ขนาดนั้นน่าจะพอดีไม่มีอะไรอีกคะที่มากไป
น้อยไปแล้วมันไม่ดีควรจะอยู่ตรงกลาง
[เพลง]
น่าจะทุกเรื่องไหม
นอนก็เหมือนกันนอนมากไปก็ไม่ดีงานทำมากไป
ก็ไม่ดีเที่ยวมากไปก็ไม่หลายๆเรื่องครับ
มากไปไม่ดีน้อยไปไม่ดีต้องพอดีพอดี
ใช่ครูเอกเป็นภูมิแพ้ควรจะนอน 7 ชั่วโมง
ถึง 10 ชั่วโมงคุณหมอให้เอ๋นอน 10
ชั่วโมง
10 ชั่วโมงสำหรับครัวตี้นะสำหรับครัวตี้
ครัวตี้คิดว่ามากเกินไป
คือคุณหมอบอกว่านอน 10 ชั่วโมงแต่เอ๋นอน
ไม่ได้เอ๋นอนน่ะ 4 ชั่วโมง 5 ชั่วโมงแค่
นี้แล้วก็ตื่น
ตั้งแต่เด็กๆนะคะเอ๋นอน 4-5 ชั่วโมงแล้ว
เอกก็ตื่นคือถ้าไม่สบายก็จะได้ 6 ชั่วโมง
หรือ 7 ชั่วโมงแต่ถ้าสบายดีก็จะอยู่ที่
เนี่ยสี่เหลือห้าชั่วโมงคุณหมอบอกเนี่ย
นอนน้อยก็เลยไม่สบายลองนอน 10 ชั่วโมง
หรือน้อยสุดก็ 7 ชั่วโมง
พยายาม
อันนี้ก็นอนไป 4 ชั่วโมงแล้วตื่นขึ้นมาก็
กลับไปนอนอีกไปนอนต่อได้ไหมหรือถ้าตื่น
แล้วนอนไม่ได้แล้ว
ก็ไม่ค่อยจะได้อาจจะได้อีกประมาณ 5 นาที
10 นาทีประมาณนั้นนะ
23:00 นตี 1 ตี 2 ตี 3  5 ชั่วโมงพอแล้ว
ถ้าครูเอ๋ก็นอนประมาณ
เที่ยงคืนหรือตี 1 ตี 2 นะคะถ้าตี 2 ครู
เอกก็ตื่น 6 โมงเช้า
จะนอนประมาณตี 2 ทุกวันนะตี 2 นี่ครู
อาร์ตี้นี่หลับสบายแล้วเชียว
[เพลง]
ยังไม่ตื่นจะตื่นมาทำไม
ประมาณ 4 ทุ่ม
4 ทุ่ม
6 ชั่วโมง 6 ชั่วโมงนะคะครูเอ๋แน่นอนตี 2
ตื่น 6 โมงเช้า
[เพลง]
ตี 3 ไงแล้วนอนอีกไม่ได้ก็เลยนอนดึกไปเลย
นะคะไม่ดีนะคะนักเรียนขอบอกห้ามทำแบบไป
นอนน้อยไปน้อยออกกำลังกายน้อยก็ไม่ดีนอน
น้อยก็ไม่ดีออกกำลังกายมากก็ไม่ดีนอนมาก
ก็ไม่ดีนะคะทำงานมาก
ใครทำงานวะ
ก็ไม่ดีครับต้องแบ่งเวลาไปเที่ยวบ้างไป
พักผ่อนบ้าง
แต่ว่าบางคนก็ทำงานตั้งแต่เช้า
จนถึง 4 ทุ่ม 5 ทุ่มเที่ยงคืนอันนี้มาก
ไหม
ก็มากนะครับก็มากนะก็มาแต่ถ้าจำเป็นก็
โอเคแต่ในก่อนในระหว่างระหว่างเวลาที่ทำ
งานก็อาจจะมีหยุดบ้างเนาะหยุดพักผ่อนบ้าง
ก็ดีนะคะเรียนหนังสือนะคะเรียนมากเกินไป
เรียนมากเกินไปก็ไม่ดีครับจะเครียด
หงุดหงิด
หมดเวลาใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ครับไม่เป็นไรได้ครับถ้านักเรียนนะคะ
มาฟังภาษาไทยนะคะมันมีคำถามที่ถามมาว่า
ต้องฟังวันละกี่ชั่วโมงต้องฟังเยอะเท่า
ไหร่ต้องฟังทุกวันไหม
ครูเอ๋ก็เลยอยากจะบอกว่าแล้วแต่คน
ใช่ไหมคะแล้วแต่คนว่าบางคนอาจจะฟังได้ 1
วันนั่งฟังนานๆ 3 ชั่วโมงบางคนได้ 7
ชั่วโมงบางคนได้ครึ่งชั่วโมงแล้วก็หยุด
เบรกไปทำอะไรแล้วก็กลับมาฟัง
ก็คือแต่ละคนไม่เท่ากันนะคะแล้วแต่สภาพ
ร่างกายแล้วก็งานหรือว่าความเหนื่อยก็ไม่
เท่ากันให้นักเรียนศึกษาตรงกลางของตัวเอง
เนาะ
อาจจะวิ่งได้กี่กิโลเมตรพอดีๆของครู
อาร์ตี้ก็คือ 10 กิโลเมตรพอดีไหม
[เพลง]
พอดีใช่ไหมคะ
การเรียนก็เหมือนกันถ้าเรียนมากน้อยเนี่ย
แต่ละคนก็ไม่เท่ากันเอาที่เรารู้สึกพอดี
แล้วก็ไม่เหนื่อยนะคะ
คือครูเอ๊ะบาดเจ็บและครูเอก็เลยคิด
ทำไมเจ็บแล้วก็มีนักเรียนส่งคำถามมาหาครู
เอ๋ว่าต้องเรียนยังไง
ถึงจะดี
ตัวเองก็เลยเอา 2 เรื่องนี้มารวมกันเพื่อ
ที่จะบอกนักเรียนว่าหาจุดพอดีของตัวเอง
ใช่
ขอบคุณครูอาร์ตี้นะคะครูเอ๋ได้ความรู้
เรื่องเซลล์
ใช่เราต้องออกกำลังกายนะครับ
หลังจะได้แข็งแรง
[เพลง]
ค่ะสำหรับวันนี้ก็หมดเวลาพอดีเดี๋ยวเราลา
นักเรียนไปก่อนแล้วกลับมาเจอกันใหม่คราว
หน้าครับ